Hello, my name is Andrew Tarvin and I am
the CEO of Humor That Works, an
award-winning keynote speaker, and a
giant nerd. And if you're wondering what
type of nerd, the answer is yes.
Computer, math, sci-fi, Dungeons and
Dragons, Star Wars, Star Trek,
Starbucks, all of them. But my mission
is to help professionals like you find
their funny and unlock their sense of
humor at work. And why humor? Why have I
dedicated the last 15 years of my career
to teaching people this surprising
skill? Why have organizations like
Microsoft, NASA, and the FBI taken time
to learn it? Why are you watching this
video? Well, the answer lies in a very
simple, very important, very dumb
question. And I want you to answer this
question in your own own head right now.
The very simple, very important, very
dumb question is would you rather do
something that is fun or not fun?
Like I said, it is a dumb question, but
it's an important one because if you're
like 99.9%
of the people that we work with, you
would say fun. So it stands to reason
then if you were to make say your emails
just a little more fun, would people be
more likely to read them? If you were to
make your own meetings just a little bit
more fun, would people be more likely to
pay attention? If you were to make your
own work just a little bit more fun,
would you be more engaged in it? And the
answer is yes. The research shows us
that there are over 30 benefits to using
humor in the workplace. These are
impressive benefits in proving
productivity, boosting overall
brainpower, and burning calories. That's
right. 10 to 15 minutes of laughter
burns as many calories as 5 minutes of
aerobic exercise, 10 minutes of dancing,
or 15 minutes of milking a cow, which
means that if you have been milking cows
for exercise, then you can stop. Or I
guess you could milk a cow and exercise
at the exact same time, burn double the
calories, right? Like
And then probably get locked up. That's
a a little bit strange.
But the crazy thing is that in today's
overworked, under-appreciated,
stress-filled, sleep-deprived world, if
you aren't proactively choosing to make
your work fun to get those 30 benefits,
you are probably passively choosing for
it to be not fun.
But we're in for a treat. We are very
fortunate because luckily using humor in
our work isn't that difficult and it is
something that anyone can do. Anyone can
learn this skill. And I know that is
true because I am someone who has had to
learn the skill of humor. Cuz I have
done over a thousand shows as a stand-up
comedian, improviser, and storyteller.
I've performed in all 50 US states, in
30-plus countries, and on one planet, uh
this one.
But my TEDx Talk on the skill of humor
has more than 12 million views and I've
taught organizations like Microsoft how
to use humor to improve communication,
people at the United Nations how to
reduce stress, and agents at the FBI how
to be more relatable and frankly less
intimidating, all using this skill of
humor. And I only tell you this
background because when I recently went
to my high school reunion and people
found out that I did comedy, they said,
"But
you're not funny."
And in some ways they were right.
Growing up I was never the life of the
party or the class clown. In fact, my
teacher I was voted teacher's pet my
senior year. And if you need any more
proof that I was not a funny person,
these were my senior photos and and I
only recently realized that this is
primarily a thing that we do in the US
and Canada where we get all gussied up
and go and take pictures with our arms
crossed for whatever reason. And if you
look very closely, you can see that yes,
I had the spiky hair with the frosted
tips like I wanted to be in a boy band.
Although at this point I wish these
pictures would go bye-bye-bye. The point
is that I was not naturally funny.
That's why I went to The Ohio State
University, got a degree in computer
science and engineering. But while
there, in addition to playing way too
many video games, I also started doing
improv and stand-up comedy. Not because
I thought, "You know who's funny? Me.
You know who should listen to me?
Strangers." No, I only did it because my
best friend wanted to start a comedy
group, meet new people, and forced me to
join. And I didn't realize until years
later that he didn't want me to join
because he thought maybe I was secretly
funny. He wanted me to join because he
knew I was organized.
And he was right. What I didn't have in
comedy skill, I made up for in comedy
project management. We practiced three
times a week. We had business meetings.
We filmed all of our shows and went to
watch back as if it was game tape. I
read books about the subject and watched
videos and did everything I could to try
to learn how to be funnier. That's when
I discovered that humor is a skill,
which means that it can be learned,
which also means that the question then
isn't, "Are you funny?" The question is,
"What kind of funny are you?" Or what
kind of funny do you want to be? Because
just like we have different
personalities, different styles, and
different taste buds, we have different
ways we express our humor. In fact,
there are seven primary ways that people
tend to use their humor, particularly in
the workplace. Either as an enthusiast,
curator, inventor, entertainer,
engineer, or advocate. Or there's a
chance that you're unsure about all of
this and might be the skeptic. But if
you want to start to enjoy your work
more, if you want to start to make your
work suck a little bit less, if you want
to choose fun over not fun, start by
discovering your humor persona. Unlock
your sense of humor at work. One easy
way to get started is to take our
completely free assessment at
humor.me/quiz.
Takes 2 minutes. You'll find out what
your primary persona is and start to
already learn some ways that you're
going to adopt it in the work that you
do. You can also follow us here for more
great humor content by clicking on
subscribe. But the reality is is you
choose every single day how going to do
your work. So, why not choose to be more
productive, less stressed, and happier?
Why not choose to get better results and
have more fun? Why not choose to find
your funny with Humor That Works.